raffi torres
comme ça
mais les démagogues
toutes tailles font taire
les endroits
les monuments et
oui
cet état
sera pas vous
vous étiez
encore
14 juillet jeu
on avait préparé
c
non
ce
derrière
jamais
un positionnement
le
[Musique]
le 15 mai 1940 après avoir traversé les
ardennes plusieurs divisions blindées
allemandes pénètre dans le département
de l'aisne avec la côte picarde pour
objectif leur progression est
irrésistible en manque de renseignements
persuadé que comme en 1914
l'objectif des allemands et la ville de
paris l'état major de l'armée française
décide de déployer ses divisions de
réserves sur la somme et sur l'aisne
un site sur les canaux qui les relie
pour gagner du temps et tenter de
juguler la manoeuvre allemande la
quatrième division cuirassée du colonel
de gaulle alors en pleine formation est
envoyé dans le laonnois officiers
supérieurs anticonformiste et
visionnaire de gaulle s'est fait
remarquer les années qui ont précédé
comme l'un des théoriciens de l'art
blindés moderniser c'est ce qui lui vaut
après maintes difficultés d'obtenir
cette affectation arrivé le 15 mai dans
la soirée au sud de laon jeune colonel
manque de moyens pour mettre ses idées
en application
homme de devoir il s'emploie toutefois
agir au mieux après avoir sécurisé ses
flancs il reçoit l'ordre de lancer une
reconnaissance offensive en direction de
montcornet où les allemands ont été
signalées ces équipages donc une
formation à complète l'ailier
résonneront radio sont défaillantes
il n'a presque pas d'infanterie et de
l'avis même de son chef d'état major
c'est de la folie mais de gaulle compte
sur le choc psychologique
l'offensive est lancée
à 4h15 le 17 mai ces chars lourds b 1
bis et des deux des bouches de la forêt
de samoussy avançant avec peine
suivant ses chars de gaulle se déplacent
partout tandis que les chars légers r35
partie de sissonne qui pénètre vers 12h
dans mon corps n'est sont victimes des
canons anti chars allemands ils ne
peuvent passer la serre
de leur côté les charlots progresse plus
difficile a encore l'essence manque
ils ne descendent vers mon corps n'est
que vers 15 heures il est alors
impossible de percer vers 16 heures de
gaulle ordonne leur repli alors que les
bombardiers en piqué allemand zew tout
cas commencent à harceler ses troupes au
même moment là trois kilomètres d'ici
commandant bescond du 46e bataillon de
chars de combat s'apprête à ordonner le
repli quand son char tombe en panne avec
son équipage il monte alors à bord d'un
autre char le sampiero corso vers 18h15
ici même
revenant vers clermont les fermes le
sampiero corso et détruit par deux coups
directs d'une pièce d'artillerie
allemande tuant tous les hommes à bord
c'est ainsi qu'à tous les hommes tomber
dans la bataille de montcornet que le
mémorial où nous trouvons grand mage ce
monument est aussi le rappel de la
victoire morale que constitua cette
bataille
certes son impact plus limité quoique
l'épisode inquiéter les allemands mais
cette épreuve du feu
l'une des sept tentatives françaises de
contre attaque en mai 1940 renforça la
confiance du colonel de gaulle et de ses
hommes
les marques au fond le début d'une
nouvelle histoire ayant reçu les
renforts de gaulle relancera une attaque
deux jours plus tard en direction de
crécy sur serre le 20 mai il se replia
au sud de l'aisne avec cette conviction
affirmé lors de son discours de savigny
sur ardres que c'est par la force
mécanique que la france vaincrait
ap
monsieur le ministre monsieur le préfet
madame messieurs les députés
messieurs les sénateurs amiral monsieur
le président du conseil régional
monsieur le président du conseil
départemental messieurs les maires
madame monsieur de gaulle
monsieur le président de la fondation de
gaulle
mesdames messieurs la drôle de guerre
était terminée
la bataille de france venait de
commencer le 10 mai 1940 les troupes du
troisième reich envahir les pays bas le
luxembourg et la belgique et déferlèrent
sur les frontières nord-est de la france
par les ardennes
là on ne les attendait pas leur percée
fut soudaine leur avancée fulgurante nos
stratégies furent balayés nos lignes
enfoncée quelques jours après la
luftwaffe pilonnaient sedan et les
panzers traversait la meuse jusqu'à
dunkerque dans la stupeur et la
sidération notre pays essuyé l'une des
plus rudes défaite militaire de son
histoire
pourtant dans ce maelström terrible la
france ne fut pas la victime consentante
de son effondrement
ni un fétu piétiné nos armées furent
battus oui mais elle lutter
et quart d'heure elle fixèrent l'ennemi
en un point du front non la bataille de
france ne fut ni une défaite prévisible
ni une déroute inéluctable bien des fois
notre destin paru sur le point de
basculer comme hésité entre la palme et
le joue et c'est aussi ce qui fit de ce
mois de mai 40 l'étrange défaite que
décrit marc bloch
elle n'était pas écrite d'avancé
l'armée française avait des failles
c'est vrai mais elle ne manqua ni de
courage ni de force d'âme
souvenons nous de nos aviateurs qui se
battirent dès septembre 39 en rivalisant
de courage pour lutter contre une flotte
plus nombreuses et plus aguerris
souvenons nous des sommes dues à nu et
de gembloux qui mirent un frein à
l'offensive allemande sur la belgique
des troupes acharné de stone des spahis
si brave de la horgne souvenons nous de
la ténacité des troupes de l'île de la
résistance héroïque des soldats et
marins de dunkerque de la bravoure des
tirailleurs d'afrique dans la somme de
l'audace sans bornes des jeunes cadets
de saumur
face à un ennemi bien supérieurs en
nombre et de l'infaillible défense de
l'armée des alpes
souvenons nous des dizaines de milliers
de vie donnée pour la france entre mai
et juin 1940
les soldats de la bataille de france
infligèrent des pertes considérables aux
troupes de la wehrmacht et retardèrent
suffisamment leur avancée pour permettre
aux alliés de se replier jusqu'à la mer
la miraculeuse délivrance de dunkerque
selon le mot de churchill permis de
maintenir le royaume-uni dans la guerre
est tout simplement d'espérer ce 80e
anniversaire de la bataille de france
doit raviver la mémoire de leur
sacrifice de leur courage durant ces
semaines terribles
les soldats français du printemps 1940
ont mérité de la patrie
ils furent des preuves dans la défaite
ceux de 40 et je sait l'attachement des
familles des villages aussi je sais
aujourd'hui leur tristesse de ne pouvoir
célébrer comme chaque année autour du
monument comme par exemple à dizy le
gros j'étais à l'instant
cette mémoire est ici à quelques-uns
nous les représentons tous oui c'est
courageux de 40
et parmi eux je veux en ce 17 mai
distinguer la quatrième division
cuirassée qui s'est illustrée ici même
sous le commandement énergique et
déterminée d'un colonel de 49 ans il est
exceptionnel qu'un colonel soit appelé
au commandement d'une division
mais ce colonel là en effet était
exceptionnelle
c'était de gaulle
ce 17 mai 40 il n'arborait encore ni
épaulettes étoilé de général ni croix de
lorraine
mais déjà celui qui emportera à londres
l'esprit de la république
l'honneur de la nation et le flambeau de
la résistance était une étincelle de
volonté face au brasier hitlérien
c'était de gaulle depuis dix ans déjà
il théorise et la guerre moderne celle
de la mécanique des chars de l'aviation
il se fit ainsi le promoteur du
mouvement et de l'offensive
le champion de l'instrument militaires
blindés et motorisé capables de créer la
vitesse et lui rue psion hélas on
l'écoutera trop peu on l'entendît trop
tard le 14 mai 1940 après la percée de
sedan la 4e dessert reçu la mission
d'attaquer les flancs du dispositif
allemand afin de couper la route de
paris de ralentir la progression des
hommes et des panzers de guderian ans
est de permettre à la sixième armée de
s'installer dans de bonnes conditions
sur l'aisne pour le colonel de gaulle
c'était l'occasion tant attendue d'agir
le 17 mai à l'aube après des
escarmouches la veille la quatrième des
cr se mit donc en marche vers ce qui
était un noeud de communication des
lignes allemandes un point stratégique
montcornet la contre attaque fut hardy à
travers chivres bussy sissonne la ville
aux bois
la progression se fie sur deux axes
parallèles carrefour après carrefour
village après village bois après bois
les blindés avancer et se rapprocher de
leur objectif
dans la matinée les français parvint à
détruire un convoi allemand
vers midi une des colonnes à tennie le
plateau de montcornet
la bataille alors s'engage à les canons
anti chars allemands firent de rapides
dégâts le feu ennemi était vif le combat
faisait rage les français en tête avec
l'âpreté de ceux qui défendent leur
terre un village voisin fut investi
débarrasser de ses poches de résistance
et demi mais en fin d'après-midi la
luftwaffe apparue dans le ciel portant
secours et appui aux panzer les
tonitruants piqué de chtouka soner alors
le glas de l'offensive française
la fougue de la manoeuvre
l'énergie de son chef et la témérité de
ces soldats menacèrent les arrières de
l'ennemi et son organisation logistique
elle trouble à leur rang et interrompit
un temps sa progression mais tenir était
trop dur les soutiens trop faible les
pertes lourdes sur infligées à l'ennemi
mais la bataille fut perdue il est des
défaites d'un jour qui portent toutefois
en elle les germes des victoires à venir
la bataille de montcornet et de celle ci
comme l'offensive se livrèrent nos
troupes deux jours plus tard à crécy sur
scène et celle d'abbeville
à la fin du mois de mai crécy sur serre
abbeville et ans de combat
au moment même où l'ombre de la
résignation et du renoncement s'étendait
sur notre pays
l'esprit de résistance se leva comme un
vent nouveau
les combats de la 4è dessert révélèrent
certes les faiblesses de l'instrument
militaire français mais les coups de
boutoir de la division de gaulle
confirmèrent qu'un dispositif porté à
l'offensive appuyée par le dévouement et
l'assurance de ses hommes commandés par
un chef déterminé dans l'action et
respecté dans l'adversité était en
mesure de battre l'ennemi chez de gaulle
cette conviction était chevillée à
l'espérance est ancré dans la raison il
l'exprima bien avant le 18 juin
depuis savigny sur ardres avant l'appel
du général de gaulle il y eut en effet
l'exhortation du colonel de gaulle
dans cette déclaration radiophonique
il s'appuyait sur son expérience pour
souligner l'intérêt de coupler division
cuirassée aviation d'attac et confiée
aux heures les plus critiques
sa confiance en une victoire finale
c'est cela qu'il nous faut pour vaincre
grâce à cela nous avons déjà vaincu sur
un point de la ligne grâce à cela un
jour nous vaincrons sur toute la ligne
mais à ce moment du conflit au sommet de
l'armée comme de l'état personne ou
presque ne partager cette conviction
bien des regards ne portait pas
suffisamment loin pour embrasser
l'échelle d'une guerre mondiale général
de gaulle confirma que sept ans c'est
jour de mai 1940 qu'il avait puisé sa
résolution juste avant les combats de
montcornet sur le chemin entre le
vésinet l'en face au spectacle désolant
d'un peuple sur les routes d'une armée
en déroute
il avait été saisi par un sentiment de
révolte et s'était solennellement juré
de poursuivre le combat où il faudra
temps qu'il faudra quand une majorité
fataliste parmi laquelle bien des chefs
militaires hauts fonctionnaires
responsables politiques pensé qu'il
fallait arrêter la guerre il avait
acquis la conviction au contraire qu'il
fallait la continuer c'est donc ici même
sur les champs de bataille de laine que
de gaulle rencontre à son destin c'est
là au plus lugubre de la bataille de
france et avant que ne sonne des heures
plus sombres encore qu'une invincible
espérances a jailli dans le coeur d'un
homme qu'elle est bientôt mener les
forces libres de notre peuple jusqu'à la
libération des français en proie au
doute et à l'abattement
cet homme pénétrer de l'amour de son
pays offrit par son exemple et par sa
parole sur les champs de bataille comme
bientôt en exil à londres sa confiance
inébranlable dans le destin de la france
c'est là son honneur et sa grandeur
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai tenu à
ce que l'année de gaulle soit lancée ici
sur les terres qui virent renaître
l'esprit français de résistance l'esprit
des soldats de l'an ii qui protégèrent
la république d opposition étrangères
l'esprit des grognards du dernier carré
de la garde ces deux bataillons qui
tinrent tête à deux armées l'esprit des
poilus de verdun l'esprit des forces
navales et aériennes libre du serment de
koufra des libérateurs du commando
kieffer des armées de leclerc et de
delattre l'esprit français
empreint de résistance et de résolution
qui souffla ici en 1940
ici comme à saumur aston et à dunkerque
l'esprit français oui farouchement libre
et fière déterminé et inébranlable qui
jamais ne meure même quand le pays est
vaincu l'esprit français qui toujours
permet au peuple de france de se
redresser et de reprendre la grande
marche de son destin
l'esprit français qui jamais ne se
résout à la défaite qui choisit la
conquête et embrasse l'audace de gaulle
nous dit que la france est forte quand
elle c'est son destin quand elle se
tient unis qu'elles cherchent la voie de
la cohésion au nom d'une certaine idée
de la france qui nous rassemblent par
delà les discordes alors devenue
accessoire et les désaccords souvent
trop vite yves colonel général
chef de la france libre président de la
république charles de gaulle incarne
cette résolution
cette force d'agir cet esprit français
vive la république vive la france
y en a bon
à tenter
oh
on va
m
vous pourrez
on va
[Musique]
à nos enfants de la patrie le jour de
gloire est arrivé
contre nous de la tyrannie ne rassemble
en effet une fois semble harel de
billets auront d où nous l echo and user
0 sonore
[Musique]
mon patron
argent
[Musique]
après un si long
beaudet
oh
le mans
la ville quelques jours après lé qui a
été encore plus spectaculaire contre les
allemands témérité montcornet même si
évidemment tout ceci se considère pas
comme une grand chose le fondamental
n'était pas là comme vous l'avez suivi
merci d'avoir fait non mais c'est un
niveau qui nous ont pour moi dont on
parle
l'invitation lancée mi mai c'était
important de
je parle en ce moment que vit notre pays
de ne pas perdre de vue le sanctionne
nous nous venons absolument la force
d'âme certain âge je crois aussi
lunaires et solaires de taille des
fermes ou des lieux on n'a pas voulu
voir l'intérieur je vous dire qu'avec
des gens valeureux nous formidable
soldats absolument j'en fais beaucoup de
blogueurs démarre très bien
non sa blessure est faible vraiment il
manquera pas de passage
france antilles
merci pour votre
finalité de mémoire d'étranglement qui
le méritent pas tous pratiquants en
particulier envers également ceux qui le
portent et sensuelle
les au delà de toutes les polémiques un
peu médiocre qui circulent donc tout ça
on demande aux terres d'origine maorie
merci lance matt stone et volières
voilà on relève patrick
mais c'est bien de rendre hommage pour
mantes combattants de l'honneur du web
le 49 d'entre eux
ces combats
je crois que on a voulu effacer cette
île
ils ont quand même permis la résistance
c'est très émouvant justement à dizy le
gros il ya beaucoup de familles qui
étaient là avec les restrictions
malheureusement toujours un club période
et d un peu tous ensuite et beaucoup
sont morts en purée novembre après avoir
pris le maquis pendant plusieurs années
faux merci en tout cas votre avis serait
ce un besoin toujours
je peux quand même
merci de rendre hommage
son récit c'est tout un symbole c'est
l'histoire qui rend hommage à nancy lui
tu la prends soin héroïque et à france m
restons inquiets félicitations
le président notation du loup provost
maire de montcornet encore pour quelques
jours et le versement pour nous ne peut
regretter que le programme initial et
été amputé de la partie montcornétois
ans faute de d'oeuvres d'art a inauguré
mais j'ai compris que leur jeu vous même
comme le swing home made by est ce mal
c'est que vous reveniez alors je ne
serai plus mr après un mandat de
conseiller municipal amant de premier
adjoint et trois mandats de maire j'ai
décidé de mettre fin à mes fonctions et
mon successeur
nous n'avons que 50 ans d'écart mais je
le connais bien parce que je n'ai eu
comme élève
merci à vous tous les résidents d'être
venu sur nos têtes je suis persuadé que
votre successeur nous invitera pour
l'inauguration du monument
merci pseudo français département
n'était pas merci à vous monsieur le
maire d'avoir fait même flambeau
merci jeu
cologna caraux président des anciens les
chars du cortège
je suis content effectivement commis
comme falcao ne soit pas oublié cette
fois ci
le portel c'est leur mémoire
merci à vous
merci pour cette évocation
angel l'europe
après bientôt au retour
je
entendre les loups et chanter
en ce jour si particulier et pendant la
seconde est mort je trouve que c'est
particulier
c'est rien
jours
mon courage
bonjour comment allez vous
département inspiré des enjeux
industriels
le v10 que tout le travail d'une
portemanteau est accompagné la merde des
choses à demander c'est l'emploi
je n'en connaissais je pense que la
période ou à s'offrir
oui mais non
à misrata
non seulement
monsieur le député je vous laisse donc
tout va bien quand on est quand même
tout l'avenir
j'espère que vous me reverrez a dit
l'apôtre est bien sûr attendre à l'ère
des records puis aussi une expression
personnelle sont hospitalisés la tuerie
je les ai remis un petit mot que je
connais merci pour toulouse
je viendrai voir avant ses avocats
reprennent nation
réserve la commune
maurice
oui et non
je voudrais au nom du conseil municipal
histoire de remercier
sans ces lieux
merci ça sera mémorable
merci monsieur
merci à vous
ça nous avoir accueillis de porter cette
mémoire et je sais combien vaut le temps
sont diffus de pas pouvoir être avec
nous
je sais bien
tout va bien tout va bien très heureux
de vous accueillir une fois plus et on
espère encore vous accueillir à nouveau
qui viennent je pense que vous avez
et puis un jour meilleur goût d'un
formidable discours qui donne envie
l'espoir est finalement très symbolique
ce comme on le souhaitait ici dans un
département qui est particulièrement
difficulté et c'est là où tout peut
redémarrer
merci pour ce discours qui donne en
élite et pardon comme en et carottes
ouais c'est vrai beaucoup de parallèles
merci
tout va bien
aussi notamment sur terre dans les
betteraves entre les éoliennes la
ruralité sept emplois
c'est vous êtes sensibles votre vie
c'est tout à fait
promesse non
ses ministres
romaine bien sûr management
c'est beaucoup
merci d'attendre le porte drapeau plus
grand bien à paris
c'est bien de 30 points d'eau
aux parents et grands parents le depor
drapeaux et vous premier de la famille
merci beaucoup merci
absolument je suis dedans
le porte-drapeau des anciens d'indochine
ainsi que le vice président de cette
même association depuis quelques mots
président du souvenir français du comité
et 4ème génération ou d'une eau coule à
tulle pour la france
nature virale
résidant dans un département qui a
beaucoup souffert pendant les deux
guerres
vous savez où jaillit souffrent d'autres
raisons sociales juillet avec vous merci
merci des combattants ont mené toi
comment avez vous appris la venue des
sénateurs et les messieurs j'essaie de
captieux aussi lui dire comme mon
collègue
n'oubliez jamais qu'un territoire de
france a subi
la chair est ce qui est toujours en
difficulté
merci pour ce que vous avez déjà fait
parce que je sais
c'est donc tous ces départements
d'avancé
les attendent déjà on va s'assurer que
ce soit fait aux bombardements
merci beaucoup
très bien
oui
merci merci beaucoup comment ça va ça va
très bien on peut voir et surtout
remercie encore passe aussi à peu aux
maux qui ont voté par les sénateurs pour
votre présence ici je trouve ça fait
énormément plaisir monde patriotique
je me suis permis aussi de
vous adresser un courrier adressé un
courrier ou
j'étais étonné comment vos cabinets
entre serment les auxiliaires de vie et
qu un courrier cosigné par la présente
des admr et
la présidente de la fepem particuliers
employeurs une situation qui est
particulière beaupré cannes
gratification exceptionnel que cette
période est peut-être revoir qui peut
revaloriser leur métier en l'espère
mandé dans les semaines les brèves
en tout cas je crois que ici c'est très
sensible au lit tu es comme partout
ailleurs en france très sensible est ce
que nous a gagné plus faste domicile le
plus longtemps possible en et meilleures
conditions possibles joue un rôle quand
est ce que le mondial
merci bonjour président donc on voit
bien par exemple se faire flinguer
toujours je me paraissait querelleurs
indisciplinés ont été sacrés - en clair
les français dans notre ans solide et il
y aura des soins toujours de vrais gens
qui ont leur place et andrew l'économie
reprenne des habitudes reprennent les
armes provenant eelv et du mono ville
monthey les terrasses culture également
touriste on n'a pas le droit nous de
d'être inquiet je devrais préoccuper les
gens ont été remarquables les français
ont été en gagner cette bataille parce
que ces deux c'est la solidité et
l'esprit de responsabilité de nos
concitoyens qui a permis de stopper
l'épidémie
louis l'époque c'est le peuple qui tire
c'est des gens mauvais traitements et je
crois qu'on leur doit aussi en effet
l'esprit compris dans cette méthode qui
permet que ce qui a été fait pendant ces
quelques semaines ne soit pas mise à mal
et de le faire en bonheur et je trouve
que les jeux restent prudents à ces
derniers jours ait montré un retour
il ya une impatience et inquiétude qui
reste c'est déjà une impatience c'est
les autres
il faut le faire en panne en blanc va
s'y atteler ensemble vous avez dit fier
de la france pression du peuple crucell
on les aimait rssi du travail fait un
signe à partir dans la région enfin
l'ensemble des élus sur tous les
théâtres d'opérations merci monsieur
et merci aux engagements aussi de la
région pour enchaîner deux volets merci
beaucoup
l'essentiel quoi entretenir leurs deux
unités qu'on entraîne l'histoire et le
passé quoi cette histoire sur laquelle
on s'appuie pour regarder vers l'avenir
et les opérations actuelles
on va attendre et voir mais merci d
entraîner merci mon colonel
merci à vous
merci et yaou
non
présentée au